نور الدين حكومه نجلاء بودا اعلنت اذا يوم
الجمعه الماضي عن ضروره الشروع في ترحيل
المهاجرين نظرا لوضعيهم غير القانونيه على
ان تبدا الاجراءات في اقرب وقت
الحكومه جاء ان عمليه ترحيلها هؤلاء
المهاجرين وايضا طالب اللجوء يجب ان تكون
في اقرب وقت لكن قبل قليل تحدثت مع اداره
المركز همم المركب الشباب هناك ضحيه
المرسى واكد لي بانه الى حدود هذه اللحظه
لم تاتي بعده اي تعليمات لترحيل هؤلاء
وعددهم 25
مهاجرا وطالبا النجوم من بلدان من جنسيات
مختلفه منها من السودان دارفور ايضا من من
مصر من غانا من نيجيريا هذا الى جانب هذا
تحدثنا ايضا مع هؤلاء الذين اكدوا انهم لم
يتم الاتصال بهم او طلب الرحيل معي الان
همم عماد وهو احد المهاجرين وايضا طالب
السودان كيف يتلقيتم خبر ترحيبكم
في الاذاعه الوطنيه التونسيه بدنا من قبل
يومين بانه علينا رح يقولون من هذه المكان
2011 كنا في تونس هنا مش يعني ليله 2011
كنا في المخيم في الجنوب التونسي منذ
اهداف ليبيا لما اجاب قصر المخيم الامم
المتحده والحكومه التونسيه هم اللي قصر
المخيم وقال لنا تمشي تونسي تونسي
علينا سكر
السنه
25 هم يؤكدونا انهم يطالبون بشيء واحد وهو
اعاده توطين في احد البلدان الاخرى سواء
كانت اوروبيه او غيرها ويقولون ايضا انهم
على استعداد لمغادره هذا المركب الشبابي
في صوره ما تم التسويه وضعتها بغير ان
السلطات الى حدود هذه تعتبر انا تواجدهم
هناك في تونس وفي هذا المركز هو تواجد غير
قانوني وهو ما رفضته العديد من المنظمات
والجمعيات الحقوقيه التي اعتبرت ان هذه
الخطوه اولا هي استنكرتها وثانيا نعم